不満が消えないってことを言いましたね
これ 消えない仕組みがあるんです
それがお釈迦様が発見したこと
世界の世界なんですね
で このダイナミズムということがありまして
これはもう 簡単に言えばそんなもんなんです
まあ私なりに説明しました
私に言えば ダイナミズムといえば全部わかって理解するだろうと思いますけどね
で なぜ物が動くのですか？といえば
不安定だからなんですね
それに素晴らしい物理学を持ってきて間違っているんだよと言わないでください
ただ一般論です で 私から見れば
ただ不安定だから動いているんです
なぜ地球が自転公転し
太陽が燃えるっていうことも
まあ不安 不安定だからなんです
なぜ物は古くなったり衰えたり壊れたりするんですかね
不安定だから そのものは
なぜ私たちの体が老いる
なんでこの肉体が老いていくんですかね？なぜ死ぬ？体も不安定だからなんです
だからずっと変わっていくんです
変化していく これがダイナミズムというんですね
英語の単語だったら まあもしかすると日本語でも何か単語はあるかもしれませんだけど
まあなかなか思い出せないんです
すごいシンプルに理解してください
ものすごい難しいんだからね
子供のレベルで理解しないと
一切の物質は不安定です
それで結論が 動かない物質はないでしょ
あのブラックホールのことはご存知でしょうに
ブラックホールは止まっていると思いますか？強烈に動いてるんですよ
なんでブラックホールは光まで自分の方に引っ張るんですかね
それくらい不安定なんですからなんです
ブラックホールっていうのはものすごい巨大な星ですけどもね
これぐらいの小さな星なんかブラックホールになりません
で これがあんまりにも不安定で
物事を自分の方に引っ張るということで
そこでもずっと変わっていくんですよ
だから一切一切の物質は不安定であるということに締めます
一切の物質は不安定です
また持ってきました こっちのページに
決して止まらないので変わっていくので
我々は物質に関わると不満になるんです
これはちょこっと説明必要なんですよ
そこで一切の物質は不安定なんですよ
止まらないんです 動いてるんです
動くっていうことは この場所を引っ越しするっていう意味じゃないんです
だからダイナミズム モーメントじゃないんです
ダイナミズムなんです
動くでもないんです 物っていうのは止まっていない
変わる とにかく絶えず変わるんです
不安定だからなんです
いくら変わっても その状態は不安定だから次に変わる
やっぱり不安定 次に変わる
やっぱり不安定 また変わると
そういうわけだから 私たちは物質に関わっているでしょ
だからすごく不満になるんです
物質が変わるんだから
まあ説明は必要ですけど
自分で一人一人でお考えになった方が
私の説明よりもいいと思いますけど
何が？何かするでしょ
我々は 例えば家を作る
あ 万々歳 良かったですかね
じゃないんでしょ 家という形になった瞬間から変わっていくんだから
もうやりきれないんです
掃除しなくちゃいけないわ
やれこれっていろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないんです
何がやってもやってもまた変わるんだからキリがないんですよ
それでもやがて壊れていくんですね
それに関わっている私たちの心に不満が生じてくるんですよ
だから家を作ったと仮定してみて
何でもそうでしょうね
ご飯食べること 仕事をすること
すべて物質に関わることでしょ
服を着ること 音楽を聴くこと
何でも物質に関わってますよ
この物質はもういつでも変わって変わっていくんだから
もうどうしようもなく
我々の心には不満が生じてくる
だからご飯食べると満足感じゃなくて不満が生じる
音楽聴くと満足感じゃなくて不満が生じる
いろいろもっと聴きたかったとかね
それも不満ですよ あの人の音楽はちょっと長すぎでした
それ不満なんでしょ？演奏会に行ったんですけど
音は低くった 低くて聞こえなかったという不満でしょ
あまりにも声がでかくて
それも不満でしょ あるいは声もいい
いい状態で 自分もいい席に座っていて
何も文句を言うところなかったら満足
そうでもない 今日はの演奏会はすごく良かったと
これなら もっと聴きたいということでしょ
あれほど見事に完璧に音も調整してもらって
自分もいいところに特等席で座ってもらってとかね
いつでもそんな調子でいてほしいと思っちゃうでしょうね
結局不満ですよ なぜ不満かというと
このものが全然止まらない
停止しない この この日本語の停止ということは
この移動ではないんですよ
だからダイナミズムなんです
そこはなんとか苦労して理解してください
変わるっていうことは
あの まあまあ 買ってきた豆腐を開けて部屋の中に置いといてください
そのまんま もう夏だから一番いいんです
その瞬間からダイナミズムでしょ
変わっていくでしょ しかし
別に豆腐は動きませんよ
同じ場所で同じ場所でいるんですけど
ずっと動いてます   一切の物質は
この物質はこの基本的な原子の世界に行けば行くほど動きが激しいんです
それ押しになればなるほど
もうつかみ所なく動くんです
その場合はもうそれ押しになったら動きだけなんです
その場合はもう終わりなんですけど
それ以外はまあ動かなくても
その場所でも変化していくんです
そういうことだから 我々生きている物質世界です
宇宙が この関わる私たちにとっては
もうどうにもならないんですよ
満足できませんよ だって何かもの
これ動く ダイナミズムで変化しているでしょうに
これでは ということで
確実にもうどうにもならなく不満が生じる理由は
物質はダイナミズムだからなんです
たまたま良いことがあっても
それは瞬時に消えていくんです
不満が生じるんです たまたま超美味しい食べ物を食べることができても
その幸福感はすぐ消えます
その幸福感で 1年生きていることはできません
たまたま物質のからくりでああ良かったと気分よく良くなる時ありますよ
気分良くなっても あの物質は変わるんだからね
だから花火を見て楽しむような感じなんですよ
瞬間で花火は美しいんだけど
次に空を見ると気持ち悪い煙で
いっぱいなんです それで次の花火はあまり綺麗に見えないんです
空が汚れているんだから
ちょうど考えるとか なんか考えが浮かぶっていうのも物質に関わること現象なんですよ
今 物質だけの話 ものがあるというのは無知な人の考えです
ものがあるということ
例えばペットボトルがあるということは無知なんです
あるじゃないんです これダイナミズムです
あると言っている瞬間でもう変わっているんですよ
しかし 皆ものがあるという前提で生きているんですよ
悪いことに ペットボトルがある
中に飲み物がある ですから
私はこれを飲むということになるんです
全部あるという前提で生きているんです
あるということはないんだから
ダイナミズムだから 本当はもうもうどうにもならない不満が生じているです
みんな感じていますよ
強烈な不満を それに麻薬つけて忘れるんです
宗教 音楽 芸術などそれ麻薬なんですよ
このあの不満をなんとか感じないようにするという
ものがあるという前提が限りのない不満を生み出す
それ説明しました 何をやってもダメですよ
虚しいですよ と思ってるでしょ
みんな ものがあるというのは
私たちの認識の誤りです
錯覚です だから科学的な真理を発見できないんですよ
科学者にさえも 数学なんだらかんだらと言うんですけど
数学っていうのは本当は成り立たないんです
もうものすごい嘘です
あれは 例えば点なんか存在しないでしょう
ポイント英語で言いますけどもね
点は存在しない 一直線？存在しないんです
よくも点と点とつなげて三角形作ったりして計算するもんですよ
１も２も存在しないよ
封土制のところじゃないんです
完全に間違いですよ だからブッダは科学やってないんです
あれほど智慧があって
ものは心で知るんだよと
やはり心を育ててみたんです
だから宇宙のこともブラックホールの存在まで知っていたんです
大宇宙が膨張して収縮していることっていうのは
いとも簡単にも言ってるんです
でも科学をやってないんです
数学に対して言っているのは
あんなのは野蛮人の学問だと
下品な学問だと 出家にはあんた方
この下品な学問をやるなよと
ティラッチャーナ・ヴィッジャーと言うんですから
ティラッチャーナというのは畜生ということでね
動物というね あんなのは動物やるもんやという感じで
それぐらい評価しています
それでお占いなんかはどんな立場なのかと
このティラッチャーナという
まあ動物たちぐらいやる
そんな程度のやるもんやって言っているのは
ちゃんとした学問なんですよ
歴史とかね 数学 天文学
インドでも当時いろいろ工学もありましたからね
医学 出家には全部禁止
まあ仏教を学ぶと あんなのを学ぶ暇余裕っていうのは当然ないんですけどね
しかし 全部すごくわかるんですよ
ブッダの教えを先に理解しておけば
俗世間の学問っていうのはもう朝飯前で
もうチャラチャラとできます
ただ やろうという勇気が出て
勇気じゃなくて いやもうあんまりその気にはならないんですね
やろうとすればすごい簡単にできる
だからあえて禁止しているんです
それで言いたかったのは
これ ものがあるっていうのは
我々の五認であって錯覚なんですよ
だからこの錯覚に基づいて成り立っている世界なんですよ
だから具体的に見ても
科学的なものは発展するわするわ
科学発展もあるわ 発明もあるわ
でもどこかでこんなはずではなかったっていうことで終わっているでしょうに
医学は発展するはそれは
それでもなんかどこかでうまくいかないんですよ
何一つとも このうまくいかないのは当然当たり前
普通なんですよ 皆様はうまくいかないと悩んじゃうでしょ
我々はうまくいかないということに笑っているの
うまくいかないよということで
挑戦はするんだけど じゃあ俺
でもうまくいくわけないんだよと
俗世間と違うところはそこら辺で
俗世間の人はうまくいくわけないんだよと言った途端
何もやらないで暮らす
こっちはとっととやるんです
とっととやるんだけど
うまくいかないことを知っているんです
だからうまくいかないのはこの初めからの錯覚ですからね
一時的にあるのを如く誤認するだけです
我々はモノはあると誤認するんですね
だからデータ取った瞬間で
頭の中で時間からずれちゃって認識するんですよ
この時間のズレがあります
それはすごく難しいポイントで
心はすごく早いし 物事も光の速度で変わっていくでしょ
だから光の速度っていうのは
物事の我々に考えられる一番高い速度なんですよ
本当はもっとあるはずなんです
スピードはわからない
私も まあ一応そこまで言わなくても
まあ一応光の速度も一番
だからこの速度っていうのはもう全く存在しないもので
スピードっていうのはものがないと
だから光っていうのはものなんですね
だから光は曲がったり
いろいろ屈折したり いろいろあります
そういうのはもう科学者の世界で発見するもので
光も曲がりますよということはみんなびっくりしちゃって
まあそれでなんとかの実験で
なんとかのもうあれ 日食なんとかで
なるほど コロナ見えるんじゃないかとかね
やっぱりアインシュタイン正しかったとか何とかとかね
まあ仏教から見れば だから何と当たり前でしょうと
しかし数学ない仏教だから
あの それは何かものにしようとはしないし
ものにしてはいけないし
そこで私たちの心にデータが入った瞬間で
次にのんびりそれ理解するんですよ
のんびり理解すると もう外のデータがもう変わってるんですね
それで私はこれ知った
これ聞いたとしちゃうんですね
それで物があるという錯覚が起こるんです
私はあの人の言葉を聞きましたと
そうすると言葉があるっていうことになるんです
言葉の場合 本当にないでしょ
喋った途端それ消えちゃうでしょうね
でも頭の中で私が言ったことは無視がするともうあの人はこう言ったという残る可能性あるんじゃないの？すごく錯覚なんですね
ダイナミズムの認識は難しい
よっぽど知識次元を変えない限りは
ダイナミズムそのものを認識することは難しいんです
いわゆる何も認識不可能な状態なんですよ
その時は 幻想として フィノーメナとして
認識不可能なところまで行ったところ
ダイナミズムなんです
だからそれは超越した地位になっています
これで物質の世界は終わります
心の世界 ダイナミズムオブザマインド
心もダイナミズムなんですね
心も次から次へとものを認識していくんですよ
認識ではなくて誤認していくんです
例えば集中して何も雑念なく集中して物事を見ていても
微妙なトラブルが起こるんです
すごい単純な例で言いましょう
あるものがあって 変わっていくと
それでステップ１０があるとしましょう １
から２に変わって ２から３に変わって
それから１０まで変わるんだと
そこで私は見ている 見ていると
私は１を見て あ １見ましたと
次に見ると そちらにあるのは４のステージなんです
あ ４ あ こういう形か わかった
次に見るぞと思っちゃうと
あるのはそれで７のステージなんです
それを見て あ わかった
はい 次に見ますと １０
のステージなんです １
から１０まで見てないんです １
と４と７と１０見ているんです
あれ 認識するための時間かかるんですよ
私は認識する間に あのものが１から２になって ２
から３になって ３から４になったところで
私は仕事終わって はい
次 あの電車のあの あの
あの切符予約したりすると
我々は並んでるでしょ
自分の国と比較するとすごくイライラするんですね
なぜかというと もう向こうはそんな機械文明じゃないんだから
全部手でやるんです だから恐ろしく速いんです
ピシピシピシピシってやってるんです
こちらは一人の人のチケットを持って
どうですか？なるほど
はい わかりました 一人に大体５分以上かかるんですよ
そこで その人でありがとうございます
またよろしくお願いします
で 次の人なんです あ ありがとうございます
それでまた始まりますからね
それで何か言いたいこと
一つの物事を完了するために
もう東京駅の新宿駅しか知らんだけど
そちらのカウンターにいる人々には５分かかります
もし人々が止まっていないでずっと動いているんだったら
どうなるんですかね 我々は並んでずっと動いて動かせる
警察とか入れて止まるなよと
そうするとカウンターの前に行った人は出て行かなくちゃいけないでしょ
そこで５分間で人々はもう１００人ぐらい行ってますけど
あのカウンターの人は次に１０１人目のはい
どうぞと取るんです だからカウンターにいる人には
あの出て行く人々を認識することはできないんです
自分のカウンター前に通すと
通り人とみんな仕事は完全にササササッとやらなくちゃいけないんです
これができない 不可能ですね
そういうことは常に存在の中に起きているんです
だから あるものが１０段階で変化することしても
私は１を見て あ １見ました
次に見ますというと もう４番目になっているんだ ２
と３は知らない そこで
私は考えるでしょ このものについて説明してくださいと言ったら
これがまずこんな形であって
次に 4番目の形を説明して
次に 7番目と 10番目を説明するだけです
それが知識だと これが知ってるんだと偉そうなこと言うんだけど
本当は正しくないんです
ですから 認識は正しくないんです
考古学の方々の説明と同じなんです
何か破片を持ってきて
割と的なことを考えて説明するんです
正しいかないかはわかったもんじゃないです
3,000年古いなんとか見つけた
世界で一番古いなんとか見つけたとか言ってるでしょ
どうかなと よく計算すること
これは 3700年前とかね
一応心はそういうふうに物事を認識していくんです
心は決して止まることはありません
そこで あの駅のカウンターの裏
後ろに座っているお兄ちゃん
お姉ちゃんたちが怠けていると思いますか？全然そうじゃないんです
ずっと仕事しているんです
一人に 5分かかっても
本人は止めてないんです
すごい忙しいんです 待ってる人から見ればくたびれますね
待って待って そこで考えてほしいのは
このあれ もう駅のあれ例でもいいんですけど
駅員は止まってるわけじゃないんです
ずっと仕事をしているんです
しかし 物質の世界はこういう感じになるんです
そこで物質も止まらないんだから
我々は止まってるんだから大丈夫ですけどね
駅員の方は 3人並んでるんだったら
3人の面倒を見ますよ
時間かけても もしそれ物質社会だったら
物質もダイナミズムだから止まらないでしょうに
それで心はずっと仕事しているにも関わらず
物事は全部見ていなくない
見てないってことになるんです
だから私たちはずっと見ているはずなんですけど
見てないんです ずっと聞いてるはずなんですけど
聞いてないんです かなり隙間が空けます
そこで間切って切って
すごいにつなげなくちゃいけないんですよ
それは自分なりの幻想になるんです
幻覚になるんです だから認識は個人個人違うんです
その上妄想もするんだったらどうなるのかと
我々はかなり時間妄想に使うんです
その時はデータ取ってないんです
心の中の感情で回転しているんです
新しいデータ入ってないんです
そうするとさらに世の中が見えなくなっちゃうんです
だから妄想する人は明らかに無知です
そこで仏教の瞑想で何に挑戦するのかというと
この妄想を止めることに挑戦するんですよ
なぜ妄想を止めることに挑戦するのかというと
この心はスピードアップしているんです
今まで見たものにいっぱい隙間あったでしょ
その隙間は減らしていくんですよ
そこで物もダイナミズムで心もダイナミズムだと発見があるんです
だからそのデータも知識も全く科学世界の知識とは関係ない
はるかにレベル高いものなんです
だから道具は要りません
何一つも 道具で見えるものじゃないんです
必要なのは集中力と妄想しないこと
私は瞑想を指導すると言うんですから
例えばこれを見た瞬間でガラスと思っちゃうでしょ
もう妄想なんです ガラスだと認識するために時間かかっているんです
その間はこれを見ていないんです
だからいつでもガラスあるのごとく見えちゃうんです
あるっていうこと 錯覚なの
これはダイナミズムなんです
年ぐらい経ったらこれ変わったなとわかるでしょうね
でも 秒以内でも変わっているんですけど
そこで皆様も経験していることが
心は止まらないということなんです
瞬間的に変化する世界と同時に心も認識も変わっていく
心はぐちゃ変わらないと
むちゃ変わらないと認識できません
そこで物を認識するでしょう
当然心は変わるんです
無常ですから 花を見る視覚と虎を見る視覚が違うんです
違うでしょうね 花を見たらあ
花だという認識 虎を見てあ
虎だよってすごい違う認識でしょうね
びっくりして怖くなったりした認識でしょうね
花見た時の気持ちと随分違うでしょ
だから心の変化っていうのはものすごく激しい
心が変わらないと 見たり聞いたりすることはできません
もし我々の心が変わらないで
生まれた時からずっと同じ心だったら
何も知ることはできません
でもずっといろんなことを知っているでしょうね
知るたびに心は変わります
心も止まることはできません
心にも止まり止まることはできません
認識するものがなくなったら妄想するんです
止まれないんだからね
例えば駅のカウンターに人が座っていて
列に人がなくなったら仕事終了ですかね
あ もうお客さんがお客さんがいないんだから
はい 仕事終わったと できませんよ
そちらは仕事中 例えばカウンターに短い時間でみんな座ってますから
一人が時間座っているとしたら
自分の名前を入れておいて
前にね 時間だよと ちゃんと時間座っているでしょうね
時間でお客さんが人が来ましたとする
人には分 分でまあ分かかっちゃう
残り分は仕事なしではないんです
それでもその人はじーっと座っているんです
時々立って別なところに行ったりもする
別なことをやったりもする
仕事中です そのように見たり聞いたりすることはない時も
心は仕事中ですよ それを妄想ということをするんです
止まらない 止まれないんです
物質は不安定ですが 不満は心の状況です
そこでなんで物質は変わるのかというと
不安定だからなんです
なんで心は変化するのかというと
不安定 不満だからなんです
そこで不安定と不安と不満という ２つの言葉が出てくるんです
不安といえば精神的なことにも使えますけど
不安定と言っちゃうと物質のこと
それでこのドラマが不安定なものと不満のもののからくりでしょ
生きるというドラマっていうのは
不満だから認識する 認識したところで不満が生じるから
さらに認識し続ける 認識したっても
認識したものまた変わっているんだから
もう君腹が立つんですよ
だからさらに認識するんです
認識も誤認でしょうに
本当は仏教で言うのは認識するならば問題ないんだよと
解決しますよと 我々は誤認するんだからね
不満も怒りなどの感情も心の性質
それから不満ということ
怒り 憎しみ 欲などなども心の性質
終わったっけ こういうものは全部心の世界
貪瞋痴やらね 怒り 憎しみ
落ち込みなどやらね 物質的なものじゃないんです
不満ということは物質じゃなくて心のことなんです
不安といえば それまた心のことで
不安定といえば物質のことなんです
物質には怒り憎しみないでしょ
ただ変わるだけ はい そういうことで
ダイナミズムのフィノーメナ
ダイナミズムオブマインドという物質のダイナミズムと心のダイナミズムというものがありまして
どちらでも一定しないもので
一定しないもの同士の関わりですよ
だから不満が生じるのは当たり前
不満しか生じないんです
不満は苦です ですから
生きることは苦なんです
断言的に苦なんです それが一般人に発見できない真理だから
お釈迦様は私が発見しましたよと
科学者にも発見できないんです
不可能です ものすごい心のスピードをアップして
心妄想することは0にして認識しなくちゃいけないんです
はい 次のセクションに行きます
心は物質に依存しているが
物質を変えたり管理したりするんですよ
そこで物質は自分勝手に変わってますよ
なのに我々の心が絡むとまた変わったりするんです
だから宇宙は偉大なりと思っても
偉大なりは心なんですよ
生きる衝動として 不満として
心は強烈なポテンシャルを持っています
そこで生きる衝動っていうのは不満なんですね
不満っていうのは強烈なポテンシャルですよ
エネルギーなんですよ
それで私はお釈迦様の真理
いくつか今教えているはずなんですけどね
専門用語は使ってない
あえて 認識する過程でさらに不満になるので
そのポテンシャルは増えるだけです
この不満がポテンシャルですよ
なぜポテンシャルかと言うかっていうと
次のものをやるんだからなんです
止まれないんです このポテンシャルという話は
専門用語で言えばサンカーラであって
業なんですね カルマなんですね
だから今日は本当は輪廻転生のからくりも説明していました
同時に業のからくりも今説明していきます
2 3行で そこで一切は苦であると
ブッダの教え 一切苦ではなくて
生きることは苦であると
もう突然に説明します
全てのものは無常であると
それも説明しました 全部ブッダの教えは全部もう広げておきました
体に関係がなくても心は回転するから死後も輪廻するんです
心は別に体があってもなくても回転するでしょ
例えばものがあると見ているんだ
聞いてるんだ 食べてるんだ
それが心だと言っても
聞いていない時でも 見ていない時でも回転しているんだからね
ということは 心には物質に関係なくポテンシャルを持ってるんだから回転することができます
この妄想できることが輪廻転生の証拠なんですよ
妄想するために必要なのは何なのかというと
怒りやら憎しみやら感情やら悔しい気持ちやら
それ感情なんですよ それって業ですからね
これまた自動発生しますからね
怒ったところで それについて妄想するとさらに怒るんだからね
だから増えるのみなんですよ
だから業っていうのはいくらでも増える
減るのはほんの微妙なんです
例えば業があって その報いを受けると業が減りますけど
ほんの僅かしか減りません
報いを受ける時も新しい業をたくさん作るんだからね
１万円を借金払う時は同時にまた 100万円をもう借りてますからね
借金増えるだけです それだったら
だから我々にはデータがなくても
情報がなくても妄想することはできますよ
例えば数学を作ったことで十分ですよ
もう輪廻転生する証拠なんです
数学っていうのは存在しないものでしょうに
でもしっかりした論理でしょ
数学はしっかりした論理です
しっかりした学問です
まあ学問と言えばほとんど曖昧ないのは
ほとんど曖昧ないのは数学だけでしょう
でもそれは残念なことに実在しないんです
それぐらいのことを心にできるんだからね
必ずしも肉体が壊れるとそれで終わりということは成り立たない
でもわからないでしょ
数学があることで 輪廻転生がある
証明しますよと言ったっても
これ誰にわかるんですかね
すごくすごく頭が良くないとわからないんで
まあそれなくても我々妄想できますからね
それから妄想っていうのはほとんどノンストップでしょう
妄想は基本的にやっていて
何か人の声が入っちゃうと
それ聞いてからまた妄想に戻るんだから
だから一番大事にやっているのは妄想の流れですから
まあ輪廻するっていうことは
もうもう明確 もうそれほどはっきりした真理がないってことになるんです
それから好き勝手に必ずもう天国に行けるとかね
これはないんですよ なぜならば
私たち希望通りに行くんじゃなくて
不満通りに行くんだからね
生き方は 勉強しないで遊びにふけている子供でも
勉強した方がいいとは知ってますよ
でも勉強に興味ないんだから
どうしても遊ぶことに行くんですよ
だから 頭で知ってる通りにはいきません
どんな人でも頭で言えば死んだら天国に行きたいでしょうね
それまた永遠だったら一番ありがたいでしょうね
そんなのは成り立ちません
いけないし 自分で天国
じゃあ天国に行く じゃあ地獄に行くとか
それはできません 自分持ってる不満によりけり
で それで心っていうのはものではありません
エネルギーなので止まることもありません
心がある 私がいるとは無知な人の錯覚です
心があるのにあるって言っちゃう錯覚なんですよ
ずっと変わっているものだからね
ものではないんです そこで我々は心があると言わないんで
私がいると言うでしょ
錯覚です だからそれは私がいるという気持ちが瞬間現れて
次の瞬間にも私がいると現れますよ
しかし 今の気持ちと次の気持ちっていうのはもう質的に違うんです
この錯覚が不満を苦難に変えるんです
私がいるという錯覚が
常にある不満を苦難に変えてくれるんです
それどういうことですかね
人の言葉を聞いていて
私にこの人はこんなことを言ってるんだぞと思ったら苦しいでしょ
腹が立ってくるでしょうに
なんで私はこんなことをしなくちゃいけないと思ったら苦しいでしょうね
だから私 本当は常に不満あるんだけど
不満は苦難になるんですね
私がいるという錯覚によって
蜃気楼と同じなんです
蜃気楼は水のごとく見える
蜃気楼が水だと錯覚すると
獣たちはそこまで走って死んじゃうんです
獣たちに蜃気楼を見えても
水のごとく見えても あれは蜃気楼だと知っていると走らないでしょ
だから不満だよ できることはと
しかし 私がいないとわかっている人には苦難がないんです
心汚して悪を犯すことにするんです
私がいるということで心が汚すんです
汚れるんです それから悪まで犯すんですね
もともと不満な生きる生きることを苦しみに不幸に溢れるものにするんです
生きることはもともと不満ですよ
しかし それが苦しみに溢れたことになるのは
私がいるという錯覚なんです
こういうセクションはそのままもう暗記するしかないんです
もうもうすごく難しいんですもん
修行でもして理解するしかないんです
瞑想する方々は瞑想進んでいくと
なんだ当たり前でしょっていうことはわかると思いますけどね
言ってるのはね 日常生活では理解しにくいんです
そういうわけで 我々は不満と苦の監獄
という中にいるんですね
不満な心は不安定な物質に依存して
満足 楽しみ 幸福を期待する
ありえないことを期待するんですね
不満な心でしょ 不安定な物質でしょ
それでからくりやって楽しみを得ようと思ってもね
得られないんです 怒り
欲などの感情に従うことで幸福を期待する
逆に怒りに従うんですよ
怒ったらいろんな人を怒鳴ったりするでしょ
あれ 幸福のためにやってますよ
怒ったら人を殴ったりするでしょ
本人が幸せになりたいんですよ
怒ったことは不安だからね
ぶん殴っちゃうんです
相手を これで幸せになれる
でも ずっと我々は感情いうことを聞く
というと逆効果なんですけど
皆様知ってるでしょ？怒ったところで
怒ってイライラして 不満で人をぶん殴ったら幸せになるわけないでしょ
問題解決したことにならないでしょ
自分がイライラしてもうどうにもならなくて
人を殺したとしたら はい
問題は OK ということじゃないでしょうに
その極端な例で考えてください
すべての感情がそんなもんで
感情の話を聞いちゃうと
逆効果で苦しみが増えるんです
自分がいるという錯覚があるが
事実はその錯覚と違います
我々に自分がいる 自分がいる
自分がいるという錯覚はありますけど
でも事実ではありません
それは それに気づくとさらに不安になるんです
怯えるんです 永遠を妄想するんです
それで皆様方も一般の人々も
こんな難しい仏教は知ってなくても
やっぱり怯えているでしょ
不満でしょう 不安でしょう
心はもう震えているでしょう
人間の 何ですか あれは
あれは私がいるという錯覚があるんだけど
生きている上でこの錯覚バレちゃいますよ
例えば 私が元気で若くて
もう大丈夫やと思って
あれ錯覚でしょ？だから年取ると衰えるとイライラもう怖くなるんです
どうしようかと だからいい加減私がいないようにすればいいでしょうに
物事は変化するんだからね
心も変化するんだから
でも錯覚のせいでそれは認めないんです
しかし みんなこの巨大な苦しみと矛盾は味わってはいるんです
特に 不満 不安 恐怖 震えることなく生はなしということで
一乗に 生きることはなしっていうことで
だから生きることは不満
不安 恐怖 震えるなどなんです